[Music]
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where does my job to
interview world-class performers and
world-class experts of different types
from all different fields my guest today
is dr. brené Brown dr. Bernie Brown is a
research professor at the University of
Houston where she holds the Huffington
foundation brené Brown and doubt chair
at the Graduate College of Social Work
she has spent the past two decades
studying courage vulnerability shame and
empathy and is the author of five count
them five number one New York Times
bestsellers the gifts of imperfection
daring greatly rising strong braving the
wilderness and her latest book dare to
lead which is the culmination of a
seven-year study on courage and
leadership her TED talk the power of
vulnerability is one of the top five
most viewed TED talks in the world with
more than 35 million views let that sink
in thirty five million views my goodness
she is also the first researcher to have
a film to talk on Netflix the call to
courage special debuted on the streaming
service in April of 2019
she lives in Houston Texas with her
husband Steve that they have two
children Ellen and Charlie she also has
a brand-new podcast just in should be
launching right about now called
unlocking us coming out March 2020 you
can find it on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts brunet
welcome back to the show I'm excited to
be here so good to see you I love your
digs thank you very much
beautiful Austin Tejas yeah although you
can't see much of it right now with the
cloud cover but I wanted to start with
two things that happen today okay
number one I'm talking to my girlfriend
this morning and she says oh who are you
interviewing today and I say brené Brown
she goes ah I love how casually you say
that and then woman downstairs won't
mentioned by name who works in the
building similar story similar reaction
and I have met so many women who are
otherwise very tightly composed who
start gushing at the mere mention of
your name and what I would love to hear
you comment on is what chord do you
think you have struck or what archetype
are you providing that gets that
response because it's not a common
I know a lot of very successful or very
famous women who do not elicit that kind
of response from people how do you
explain that no idea no idea no idea I
don't know yeah do you know I have
perhaps a theory I mean the only other
person I've heard elicit similar
responses is Esther Perel
so I have her I have to imagine she's
great that has something to do with
vulnerability but is it just that I mean
what is the feedback that people give
you okay so I do have a theory and I
don't know I don't know if this I don't
know if this is the driver of that
reaction because it's still shocking to
me like normally like if someone if I
walk up and someone goes there
I still like look behind me like what's
happening like you know or mostly I'm
looking for danger because I'm wired but
here's what my new theory is my new
theory is that it's not that people I
mean people I think appreciate the
research they appreciate the work but I
think what really connects to people a
kind of a cross-gender
is what they really like is watching me
struggle with my own work hmm so rather
than being someone that's like here's
what we should all be doing and I've got
it all figured out I'm like this [ __ ]
sucks like and if I didn't think we had
to do it I'd be like no way in hell am i
doing this and so I think it's a
combination of giving people language
for experiences that we all have and
then being really forthright about how
much how hard it is for me and how much
I hate it sometimes mmm joana mean I
think I do
watching the struggle in the description
of your new podcast yeah be launching
shortly and is already dominating the
charts of the preview congratulations
I'm excited one of the phrases that
stuck out to me and I might butcher this
slightly but it was something like the
magic and messiness of relationships or
the human condition but the magic and
the messin
so maybe what you're speaking to is not
providing the highlight reel which I
think yes common totally but also giving
people the the lowlights which are part
of everyone's experience yes I'm like
not a fan it's like the ESPN play of the
day yeah like they're like five thousand
six hundred ninety four pop flies missed
you know it's like and you know and then
that means there's like the three
hundred out filters they're in a shame
shitstorm and you know and like to me
that's much more interesting than the
play of the day yeah yeah I like to play
the day I watch them play of the day I'm
a big sports person but I don't often
make the play of the day yeah yeah which
is which is precisely why when every
once in a while I'll talk to some one
involved the medium they're like can we
shadow you for a day and I'm like
absolutely not now it's as it's 99% just
like missing missing the pop ball and
having hit me square in the face that's
99% of the day and I'm like that's not
gonna make for compelling media coverage
no and I get asked that sometimes too
and I'm just like well first of all no
because like like okay I'm making a
lunch for school you know for my kid
going to school I'm unloading the
dishwasher you know like it's and yeah
this goes into a whole different topic
but I also have like there's a line like
this is my life you know like the people
I love can't follow me mmm so it's
strangers are definitely not following
me I don't like anybody enough how did
you and I know we we spoke about using a
certain format for this conversation
we'll get to those okay but I'm curious
as someone who as best I can tell was
not trying to become famous
you gave your TED talk that now has 35
plus million views some of the top talks
of all time so it seems from the outside
looking in that you're sort of thrust
into becoming a public figure how did
you navigate determining where to draw
lines and boundaries well I don't know I
it's still a daily practice I'm still
drawing them every day and I'm
readjusting them every day but I I'm so
grateful that
this didn't happen to me when I was
younger because I don't know there's
like this working theory that a friend
of mine Jennifer shared with me that she
said I don't know that anyone who is
trying primarily to be famous has
anything interesting to say
and I think part and I think that's true
like I I I didn't want to be I don't
know that I'm famous but I didn't want
to be a public person because I'm too
self-conscious for that really to be
honest with you like and I'm I'm a tough
person but I get my feelings hurt and so
when people make fun of what I look like
or what I say or if I use the wrong word
or mispronounce something like it can it
can take me down less than it used to be
able to less than it did it I guess but
so I didn't really want the public part
so when that first start happening after
the TED talk I already had a team
together because I was I want to get
mascara I work I wanted to get to as
many people as I could with my work
I just wanted to stand like down and
push my work into the world mm-hmm
and not be there's a lot of people whose
workers in the world but they don't we
don't know who they are
but again going back to your first
question I don't think it's my work I
think it's me as a vessel for the work
that resonates with people because I
think I am it's like a terrible paradox
it it is a terrible paradox it's just
I'm having a moment like that
it's my ordinariness that makes me
relatable and it's also my ordinariness
that makes me where I take all the hits
do you know Jim I do and I also think I
mean I'm not gonna a would over over
drinks maybe debate the ordinariness but
I I do understand what you're saying and
and I think that in your displaying of
your fully imperfect self which we all
are in that ordinariness
doing what you do and putting your work
into the world as you have is
extraordinary and so I think that may be
a piece of why people connect and find
it so inspiring right as opposed to
seeing like a LeBron James whoever it is
going well that's that guy is a mutant
yeah there's that that is a separate
planet there's no there's no room for me
to aspire to emulate that because it's
so out of reach does that make that make
sense yeah it totally makes sense
whereas when you are very vulnerable and
discuss the struggle people go oh [ __ ]
that's how I feel I didn't know people
who do things like put work into the
world in a TED talk and this that and
five best-selling books and so on could
also feel that way and oh yeah the work
that they do yeah so yes I definitely I
definitely feel that way I mean I think
and I think the people who follow my
work for a long time we're kind of just
growing up together and learning
together I mean when I started I didn't
understand that I could be brave and
afraid at the same time and now I kind
of live in that I'm like I'm I feel
brave right now cuz I'm with you here
doing this but I'm also afraid and I'm
like I'm literally thinking how much
longer can I hold in my stomach and talk
to him and at some point I'm just gonna
have to like breathe I shouldn't have
worn the clingy like Rolling Stone shirt
I should've worn something like puffier
so I could breathe like like I'm just a
normal person but but yeah I'm just a
normal I am a really I think we're all
kind of ordinary people I get to do
extraordinary things but I think we're
all ordinary people but I think
sometimes this world is tough because we
shame and diminish ordinary mm-hmm
ordinary lives or small lives you know
ordinary moments are you know we chase
extraordinary moments instead of like
being grateful for ordinary moments
until until hard [ __ ] happens yeah and
then in the face of really hard stuff
illness
loss the only thing we're begging for is
a normal moment like oh my god can I
please have that ordinary moment back
mm-hmm you know can I please hear this
him come through the screen porch door
can I please get a call from my mom or a
crazy town like then we want the
ordinary moments but in them with all
the noise it's about the extraordinary
right now and I'll tell you a true story
I'm debating right now whether I should
tell it or not because it's so fresh but
I just had to do a photo shoot for the
podcast like the image for Apple
everyone to use and I was the
photographer was great
Randolph Ford and it was it was fine it
was at the hotel st. Cecilia here in
Austin which was a really fun place to
do it please so you know I'm like
uncomfortably like you know doing that
like helmet how much how much is to to
fee you know that whole thing and they
said well come and look at the monitor
they're great and then I stepped around
to look at the monitor
and it was such a shock to me because
this was the thing playing in my mind
like I am 54 I Know Who I am I really
like Who I am but then I'm looking at
this monitor and I'm like oh my god
because my training for 54 years has
been why are you taking pictures and
having all these fancy people here when
you're not perfect looking like this is
this is the realm of perfect people like
models do this and you're like but to
see on these big screens with all these
professional people against a white
backdrop like me I'm like oh my god this
is this is not what we normally see in a
photoshoot behind the scenes right and
it was just this moment that I do such a
metaphor for life it's like I earned
every single one of these F and wrinkles
and stretch marks like and this is the
body you know that phrase my kids and
you know like but that ordinary Ness can
almost be for those of us who haven't
found a way to love it in ourselves
repulsive hmm you know like the realness
the realness like this is me so like
when they were to when they were doing
the photos like get ready and
photoshopping the photos so I was like
you know make sure that you make that I
look my age because I don't like that
like shocked you know how when I show up
someplace and they're like damn was at
an old photo you know like really
grappling with and I'm just gonna say
these things out loud
hmm do you know where like because and
maybe that's why people are like oh
thank god someone's saying them out loud
yeah because they're normally relegated
to our secret shame lives yeah you know
and we all have them
yeah oh for sure right yeah well I'm
glad that you are that's how odd to put
it this way I was showcasing that right
I mean it's I think it's I think it's it
provides a sigh of relief to a lot of
people who feel like they have to keep
all this things relegated or to do it
will feel like they have to divorce
those parts of themselves in in some yes
yeah and I think it's I think it's there
is a divorcing there's an orphan event I
would say that you know of these parts
of ourselves and it's not like you know
it's weird too because people always say
this is an interesting question I should
ask you this question fire away
people always say where's the line
between embracing imperfection and
vulnerability and kind of our humanity
and striving for excellence mmm yeah
janna mean and absolutely and I'm a
striver like I'm a like you know like
we're serious about our brand and my
work and attributions and I work out all
the time and you know you asked me to
before we started we were checking like
what do you have a breakfast I'm like
I'm intermittent fasting just need 10
seconds of audio what do you fantasize
ready for lunch
alarm key dobar so it's not like you
know it's not like embracing your
imperfection is giving up yeah but what
do you how do you answer that question
if I said Tim mm-hmm where's the line
between being our best selves or
striving for excellence and embracing
who we are funny you should ask because
we're recording this in January 2020 and
I thought a lot about this on years even
in the few days after the passing of the
new year when I was going through notes
and photographs and everything from the
past year and I'm actually still doing
that review I mean we're well through
the midpoint of January and I'm still
doing my last year review and one of the
conversations with my girlfriend with
some of my best friends was this topic
exactly and I can tell you where I
landed because I wanted to try to get
the right phrasing for me of the
question so I talked about the line
right like that and there are a number
of different versions of the question
one was how can you be self accepting
without becoming complacent like that
was one right that's great that was one
and then that's good you know how can
you conversely like how can you be high
achieving without being
self-flagellating herself abusing and I
thought about another good one I thought
about the line as you phrased it I
thought about the line and I realized
that I had trouble answering that
question like where the line is so the
question that I started to ask myself
which was informed by a book I've been
reading for the last month or so called
already free which is written by a
boulder based psychotherapist who also
is a Buddhist contemplative and he would
be the first to say these two do not
mesh they actually contradict each other
in some ways but you can make room for
and use both so informed by this book
with just reading during the passing of
the new year I thought to myself maybe
the question is how can I make room for
both striving and Celtic self
septons and so this might seem really
clinical and boring but i just scheduled
blocks of time for both and practices
for both so for instance there's a
journal called the 5 minute journal and
part of that is what I'm grateful for
three a bullets
what made today great three bullets and
those are generally small things
sometimes they're big things but I try
to include at least one small thing so
that I don't become myopically fixated
on the extraordinary right right and
because I think one of the risks of
being heavily achievement focused is
that you only give yourself a pat on the
back when you've done something that is
the equivalent of a home run talk or a
massive project launch or setting a
world record some type in your mind and
you can become really miserable that way
so in my personal life driving and
achievement being in gear six is and has
been forever the default right and I
think that's a coping mechanism for a
lot of things that happened when I was
younger but nonetheless that is the
default so the self acceptance is
putting things in the calendar as
practices that will ensure I take time
for that because my experience is that
if I don't put them in the calendar they
just get squeezed out by everything else
how do you how do you think about it
well I'm changing in real time because I
love the make room for both but I think
the only place that I have come to
around using my question about the line
where's the line between complain I love
that complacency and what you say
complacency and self-acceptance a place
in south acceptance and complacency and
for me I always think where is the line
between I'll just take it to my to our
organization and my role is a leader in
that organization we believe in
excellence and beauty in all things and
we are not jacking around like like if a
fonts wrong I will notice it mm-hmm so
where is the line between excellence and
beauty and all things and perfectionism
that is paralyzing
network gets out so there's always you
know where's the line between my
perfectionism and my being my best self
I the only thing I've come to you so far
that has been the shift for me between
it's a midlife shift I think it's a
midlife shift for everyone and it's
taken me a good five years in midlife I
will determine the line you will not
determine the line for me hmm so I know
I know that for me it doesn't matter
what I'm achieving are accomplishing if
I'm not eating in a way that makes sense
for me working out and sleeping that it
doesn't matter so like for whether
you're saying boy you need to you know
lose 30 pounds or you're on the side
where you're like healthy at every you
know whatever it doesn't matter I don't
care what you think
on either side what I think is I know I
need to work out five days a week
mm-hmm I know that I need to eat this
way I know I need to write down what a
meeting I need because otherwise I'm
like I can be a stress carb person so
for me the day I reclaimed that line as
internally set not externally that was a
huge changer for me but I do think I
need to make room for both I I'm gonna
look into that like I it is very
Buddhist it is not the competition
conflict thing yeah yeah and what this
author I'm blanking on his name but
we'll put it in the show notes what he
uses his labels are on the on the
western psychotherapy side he talks
about the developmental view so you look
back at the the outdated strategies that
have become patterns in your life that
are no longer applicable or are being
overused and then you take steps to sort
of improve or change your behaviors and
that that would include your thought
patterns and then the on the Buddhist
side I would just say if Buddhist as a
word bothers you just on the awareness
side he would call it the fruitional
view which is being effectively becoming
in cultivating the ability to be okay
with whatever is and so another
aspect of this that I've been thinking
about a lot is there is there is there
are different types of self acceptance I
think this is really important it's only
something I've thought very closely
about in the last handful of years
because I spent most of my life hating
myself at best tolerating myself for
moments but there's a lot of
self-loathing driving performance and I
for a long time viewed any type of self
acceptance as complacency this is self
acceptance equals complacency period
yeah and you need to be your own devil
whipping yourself in the back to try
harder what I've realized and this is
informed by a lot of reading of course
is that there's there's there is
complacent self acceptance where you say
everything I'm doing is just fine I
don't need to change anything and I
shouldn't change anything I want to just
stop there for a second you can edit it
but I'm a poser I need I have to think
there is such thing as what and I can
modify I can modify but I want you say
what I said is I do think there are
multiple types of self acceptance right
and that let term self-acceptance could
be used to excuse complacency in the
sense that you could say I am practicing
self acceptance which means everything
is great
everything is as it should be lalala I
don't need to change anything but then
I'll add one more piece there's there is
a self-acceptance which says for
instance as an example I'm making this
up like right this back right now I am
nervous and I'm frustrated and I'm angry
because a B and C is happening in my
life and we're doing this podcast and
I'm bald now unlike in 2007 and oh my
god I'm like it's my head just a shiny
cue ball on camera right now bla bla bla
and I could accept all of those things
as true because they are those are my
experience and then for some of them I
could resolve to take steps to improve
upon those things right so there's a
situation I need to fix great let me go
fix it because that's making me or
agitating me in some way so I think that
there are there's a there's a self
acceptance which is a macro I don't need
to change anything and then there's a
self-acceptance which is really just
truthfully accepting whatever you're
experiencing at the moment as what is
happening as a
I don't want to feel angry I don't feel
angry and like fighting and fighting and
fighting and tugging yourself in
multiple directions so that might sound
kind of esoteric but for me it's been
very profound in that you can be
forgiving of whatever you are
experiencing in your body in your psyche
in the moment while still putting in
place steps to improve whatever it is
you're hoping to improve right I think
it's possible to do both I think it's I
think it's possible to do both - I do
because I think I live F and I do I go
back to like the union belief that the
paradox is the only real thing that is
has enough tension to to capture human
experience so I think you can have self
love and self acceptance and want to be
better in other in ways I think and in
fact I don't think you can change
without ok so here here here the
pairings I want to unwind mmm I don't
think you can truly change for the
better in a lasting meaningful way
unless it is driven by self-acceptance I
agree that so I think being the [ __ ] out
of yourself for performance which you
know I work with a lot of sports people
now like it works and if all you have to
do is pay someone for one season or all
you do is one game or one whatever
you're okay but lasting meaningful
change has to be driven by
self-acceptance you know the other thing
that is just so shocking to me about
complacency and self-acceptance
is as I think back and I would really
have to go into the data but just
sitting here I don't think I have ever
come across a single person who I the
not a single person that I can think of
who was complacent driven by
self-acceptance like I don't think I
don't know I don't know that that is not
an act oxymoron
I got to tell you that like self-aware
complacency
doesn't work for me as a constructs
self-aware no I don't are yourself
accepted complacency yeah I don't know
that I believe that yeah you know I'll
push all push a little bit you're going
to have to look on your face yeah I
would say and I think that I'm
struggling for the right terminology but
I think we all know people who are
alcoholics have various issues and they
are in denial of having problems yes let
me stop you there yeah and say that is
neither self-awareness nor
self-acceptance definitely not
self-aware it's not self-acceptance
either well I would I maybe there's a
better word but I would just say that
there are people who are delusional to
the extent that they either believe they
don't have a problem that they have or
they have a problem and refuse to accept
it as a problem
I think we're sure right so so and we
can go a lot of directions with this but
I would I would say that I think we can
agree there are complacent people there
are complacent people and among those
complacent people I think there are
those who hate themselves
there are those who sort of love
themselves and are narcissistic and I
know a number of these and then there's
a lot in between and I think that you
there are complacent in some respects
complacent narcissists who almost by
definition being a narcissist love
themselves so is that self acceptance
maybe yes maybe no I would say that it
is but it's a disabling self acceptance
whereas to your point about lasting
behavioral change I think that at least
psychologically if you are divorcing
parts of yourself if you hate parts of
yourself aspects of yourself that have
been informed by your history that and
I'm borrowing this phrase from somewhere
else but like what you resist persists
right and that in that you are going to
carry that unproductive and in some ways
self-defeating tension
within you even if someone is forcing
you to change your behavior or
incentivizing you to change your
external behavior right and so even if
technically you're changing a behavior
if you if you carry self-loathing even
partial self-loathing with you hating an
aspect of yourself or certain emotion
within yourself I view that as a loss
agree yeah so you know this is this is
getting out there a bit but this this is
this is the type of stuff that sometimes
I worry that I lose that I've lost my
audience can I make a confession yeah
because for a long time I was thinking
about writing a blog post about this but
for a very long time if you look at all
the books that I've written
it's like book on entrepreneurship book
on physical performance book on
cognitive performance and learning for
our chef etc etc it's mostly
developmental it's about improving
performance in one or more areas and now
what I've spent more and more time on
like we're spending time on it right now
is the inner game for her and the
importance of developing a keen level of
self-awareness so that you can examine
the contents of your this is going to
get super woohoo for a second we're just
gonna separately the contents of your
consciousness right like wherever you go
you're carrying your mind with you and
so to develop a familiarity with that I
think is the the crux skill that
underlies everything else and you and I
both know plenty of achievers who are
miserable who are fresher
high-performing well known people who
are utterly miserable and to me the
question of why is that how can that be
the case is the question that I'm
extremely interested in these days and
but I worried that having built an
audience who is largely but not entirely
kind of go go go
rah rah rah win win win there's nothing
wrong with that but people who are
trying to develop skills and the
competitive advantages and so on that
then I may lose a large portion of those
people in shifting and talking about
more of these things
we'll see where it goes but that's
something that has occurred to me and I
think I'm willing to make that trade I
think I'm willing to to take that if
that's a cost of doing business I don't
know so a couple of things one the Go Go
Go audience that you've built you this
may scare them but I mean ask someone
who works with elite athletes and
professional folks and CEOs and those
things what I can tell you is this is
the hardest challenge you've issued hmm
like and it's not about the conceptual
complexity of what we're talking about
it's about unlocking performance is one
thing unlocking people yeah way harder
way scarier and unlocking ourselves and
creating self-awareness to me it to me
you would be remiss not to go here
mm-hmm because you know I don't know I
think like something you said when you
were talking about we all know a lot of
narcissists and they love themselves but
that's actually not true do you know
that narcissism is the most shame-based
of all the personality disorders
narcissism is not about self-love at all
it's about grandiosity driven by high
performance and self-hatred it's you
know I define it as the shame based fear
of being ordinary and so you have to me
you have this audience that and I'm one
of them I mean like and I'm probably an
outlier I guess and it's like me being a
rush fan like but there's always
outliers like 40 40 to 50 percent female
but I wish it yeah yeah it is yeah it's
it's shifted a lot in the last handful
of years yeah but I think you know when
I get invited in by a fortune 50 CEO and
you know and he or she says look we need
help we need help with the team we need
they're not asking me to help with time
productivity right they're not helping
me to set up a scrum or agile process
for software development they're saying
you know we're at each other's throats
we hate each other it's a shame based
finger-pointing like it's all about
self-awareness and chain
those behaviors and to me you know to me
the hard thing about this this area in
your work is a lot of what I've learned
from you that has changed my life has
been not only effectiveness base but
efficiency based and so where you can
lose people with this conversation is
this is not an efficient process yeah
all right
Jinna mean there's no I don't think
there's a four-hour self-awareness it's
like no plans to write that yeah but I
mean but like but people would love it
if you could you could unlock that fast
but to me this is the capstone
conversation for you yeah Jenna me like
I do cuz what's it all in for yeah
you know like a bit I'm winning I'm
smart I'm successful and I'm on my third
marriage and I don't speak to any of my
children
yeah like would you see a lot or not I
see all the time yeah right because I'm
going to tell you not to dismiss the
importance of that work that's easier
yeah yeah it is easier it is easier you
know because the thing about these
conversations that you know I end up
having every time we sit down oh there's
a second time that both times we've sat
down is what what differentiates us as a
social species is the need to be seen
and known and loved and the need to see
and know and love others and no one
rides for free like we all come into
this adulthood with hard stuff and what
I would say is true about complacency
and 95% of what I see that people call
pathology is its armor yeah it's not its
armor it's how its behaviors and ways of
thinking that I've developed to protect
myself from being hurt so I have a
question I'll tell you about that no
it's not reaching
so you get your good
so my question related to Armour is I'll
get to through a segue which is a quote
that I want to say Tara brach the
well-known meditation teacher also
writer radical acceptance is a fantastic
book shared with me which I'm gonna
paraphrase and it's along the lines of
you know a great sage once said there's
only one real question that matters and
that is what are you unwilling to feel
I've thought about that a lot and not to
say I have any concise answers to that
but I think it's I think it's I think
it's an anecdote really worth meditating
on I've thought about it what do you say
to the people you meet who are on the
third marriage their kids don't talk to
them and there are certain things that
they have convinced themselves
subconsciously or otherwise maybe
through an abusive upbringing or trauma
whatever it might be
that it is unsafe to feel certain things
and you come in they've asked for help
but they do not want to open Pandora's
box right they do not want someone to
drag them into the deep waters of
emotions that they've kept under lock
and key for so long how do you help
someone like that what do you suggest to
them because it does get messy it's
gonna get messy before it gets clean
least in my experience it's like you oh
you're gonna do spring cleaning guess
what you gotta take all the things are
up on the up on the shelves all the
things in the drawers all the things
that are hanging on coat hangers and
you're gonna put them in the middle of
the room and it's gonna be a mess it's
gonna be a [ __ ] mess you're gonna be
pissed that you did it and that is it
and that is but you can't really get
past go without that type of step so for
someone who's listening to this and says
you know what I buy it like I get it and
yet what do I do because I've been I've
had on this armor for so long so I would
say a couple of things and the first
thing I always feel like is really
important to say is that I'm a
researcher and so I'm not a therapist
that would be differentiate me
Esther like I don't see clients if I go
in and I'm working with CEOs and this
question comes up all the time what I
would say to people is Pandora's box is
closed right now but are you under the
impression they were living outside of
the box or in the box like you know I
like that
yeah I mean like you don't want to open
Pandora's box because that's strange to
me because you're living inside
Pandora's Box and what I feel like
you've asked me to come here
to open it up like we're not going to do
this process without walking through
some deep [ __ ] where there's going to be
deep Swift water and if the water is
super deep and Swift you need to go
through that with a therapist and get
that that settle before we work in the
organizational way but what I would say
to people what I always say is is the
same for me and I'm sure the same for
you
that we all grew up and experienced at
very varying degrees trauma
disappointment how you know hard stuff
we armored up and at some point that
armor no longer serves us and so what I
think I would say to that person is how
is not talking about this serving you
hmm
like I've been sober for 23 years so
someone in a would be like how's that
[ __ ] working for you hmm
you know like but I probably would put a
softer spin on it than that
over black coffee to cigarette but you
know but I would say that it's not
serving anymore
mm-hm and now the weight of the armor is
too heavy and it's not protecting you
it's keeping you from being seen and
known by others and so this is I mean
just tell you Quinn essentially this is
the developmental milestone of midlife
from late 30s to you know through
probably your 60s this is the question
hmm
yeah this is when the universe comes
down and puts her hands on your
shoulders and pulls you close and
whispers in your ear
I'm not [ __ ] around you're halfway to
dead hmm the armor is keeping you from
growing into the gifts I've given you
that is not without penalty time is up
hmm so this is what you see happen to
people in midlife and it's not a crisis
it's a slow brutal unraveling and this
is where everything that we thought
protected us keeps us from being the
partners the parents the professionals
the people that we want to be and there
are only I've only seen this is a fork
in the road I've only seen two responses
to this visit from the universe well
there's I guess there's there was my
response which I was like screw you
bring it like you think you can do you
think you can best me and then it was
just one nightmare situation after
another until yeah you're not gonna win
that fight right I think if you say you
know what I'm not I'm not gonna do it
then you've got to double down these are
the people that walk through the world
double down on their own [ __ ] in denial
you know cheek squeezed as they walk and
cause so much pain in the world
yeah to themselves as well I mean yes
because it is so much easier to offload
pain than to feel pain yeah and so you
really have a choice in midlife whether
you're going to be you're gonna you know
identify into the first step of it the
whole process is what Armour and I'm not
saying like I'm not saying just pull off
all the armor and streaked through
Austin because I think you can't replace
the armor with something hmm I think
it's curiosity is what you replace that
you just become very curious about
yourself about the world why did I react
that way when Tim asked me that question
I wanted to like hit him over the head
with a topo cheaper model you know what
was going on there Jenna mean like what
is my obsession about this you just
become very curious is curiosity
is really the superpower for the second
half of our lives because it keeps us
learning it keeps us asking questions
and it increases our self-awareness but
when you see and I think it's really
hard because you know I'll walk into a
situation and they'll be the person who
invited me is usually the CEO and then
you'll have like the cross-armed pissed
off clenched cheek like if you look in
person usually in operations or
technology you know and then they're
like what's the business case for you
being here you know like because you
know here's our stock price here's
what's going on here's our evaluation
like why what it what do you need and
then you know the CEO usually say
[ __ ] hate each other and this can
only last for so long like you know it's
the end of every great band right like
this is gonna come to an end and it's
gonna be terrible and so I don't know I
think you can't pull it all off at once
you have to there's for a lot of people
for all of us there's trauma yeah and
people are like no there's not trauma
for all of us there's trauma for you
know people who had been abused
physically sexually emotionally there's
trauma for people of color and people
who have been on the margins there's
trauma for all of us it's just different
levels of trauma yeah you know I mean to
escape childhood with nothing is I
haven't met that person yet no I haven't
either
right so the trauma staff literally the
trauma message in our body is you take
this armor off we die so you protect us
at all costs and leave this on a lot of
that work has to be done with a
therapist yeah yeah there's some really
good books mean there are a lot of
terrible books on this type of topic but
the thing it's the body knows the score
or the body keeps the score but so the
endow card yeah yeah bestival vendor
brilliant is is very interesting in
terms of tying the the the physiology
and somatic experience into these past
emotional experiences and you know what
you were saying about Pandora's box and
the question which I liked of
do you think you're living outside of
Pandora's box or used locked inside
Pandora's box is is a really insightful
question and also reminds me of
conversation I had with a friend of mine
news editor who had a very very tough
time multiple divorces fortunately on
good terms with his kids but a lot of
interpersonal strife and he said what no
doubt you've heard a lot which is like
I'm not sure I want to go there I'm not
sure I'm ready to sort of open that not
sure I'm ready to deal with it and what
what occurred to me as I was listening
because I experienced this for a long
time is oh you're dealing with it your
choices do you want to deal with it
head-on
in the sunlight or do you want to have
have it come oozing out of the corners
in the darkness where you can't contend
with it in a direct or systematic way so
you're dealing with it no matter what
the question is how are you dealing with
it and great Jungian saying keep your
shadows in front of you they can only
take you down from behind oh I like that
I like that yeah you're dealing with it
like like here's the thing emotion and
cognition undefined and unexplored drive
every decision you make I mean you
either develop self-awareness are these
things control you I mean it's but it's
really I have to say that it can as
someone who chooses affect or affect
words carefully it can be terrifying for
people yeah but rarely does anyone
around them who knows them like you with
your friend say oh my god I'm shocked to
hear this when the reveal comes out yeah
you're like your whole life has been
defined by this yeah and I would I would
also like to say and this is this has
just been my experience and my
experience observing a pretty
decent-sized group of close friends who
had this realization in the last say 10
years that the process of becoming
curious about your subconscious
programming and the old scripts and the
armor can feel messy and it probably
will be messy and it'll feel terrifying
but not all changes need to take 20 or
30 years like some changes can in my
personal experience at least I had some
terrible things happen to me as a kid
and in the last say five years with the
right tools and the right prompts and
the right books and the right
accountability partners like my
girlfriend who is a very well developed
empath and a very clean fighter which is
really important huge huge and one thing
that she does really well that has been
instrumental for me she's been the
clearest mirror maybe I've ever had in
the sense that I have my stuff she has
her stuff I have my scripts and my
sensitivities many of which are out of
date and we set time to do what we call
batching so rather than having lots of
interspersed criticisms or constructive
pieces of feedback that may not be taken
the best way by by me especially at 3
p.m. on a weekday will set time aside to
sit down and we will take turns and this
is a format it may not be the best
format but it's something we came up
with it works for us where we'll tell
the other person what they're doing well
like what they're really doing well what
we think we are doing well and then
we'll ask for what we would like more of
and in that format you can start to spot
patterns right so if you do that once a
week or every two weeks sort of things
come up I'm like oh well the first time
you said that I thought it was just an
exception but now I realize that is a
pattern that I have right when X Y & Z
happens I go like let's talk about it
later don't deal with it now and I sort
of shove off certain types of topics or
questions
and then you can be you can begin to
experiment with working on alternatives
and the reason I'm saying all this is
just because I don't I don't want people
to feel like the curiosity if you're
willing to take that first step
about your patterns your programming
these added eight strategies is an armor
does not necessarily lead to you trying
to run an ultra marathon with a
blindfold on like there are there are
actually tools and resources and books
and methods that can be really really
really helpful in short order and and
you'll be surprised I mean it's really
like it's like putting off the mammogram
or you know the prostate check or
whatever it is that you have to do
putting it off putting it off all the
[ __ ] you make up about it all the scary
stories you collect as many horrible
things as you can and then you go and
you're like wow the fear leading up to
this was so much greater so much more I
mean I'm not saying it's not gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt but I do think I mean
the two hacks that we have Steve and I
have been together for 32 years
date off and on for seven years and
married for whatever the Delta is there
25 or whatever married now hardest thing
I've ever done
hands down hardest thing I've ever done
y'all hear me out there hardest thing he
and I both come from our parents
marriages on both sides divorce
remarried several times [ __ ] shows we
had no idea what it was supposed to look
like right we just we're willing to keep
showing up and the conversations like
you and your girlfriend have we do that
too it's uncanny how similar it is yeah
yeah especially what we want more of
what's really working
I really appreciated this this week we
try not to if it unless it needs to be
done in real time we'll usually wait
until we're in a good place to do it you
know and and and I I don't know I don't
think that he saw dirty fighting but all
I saw was dirty fighting I'm like you
know you know shame humiliation
put-downs
you know stuff that leaves marks stuff
that you can't and I and I can default
there when I'm in
a powerless corner I can come out like
mean it's hard to believe but no it's
really not
I throwing elbows and head bucks yeah it
for sure I can kind of and verbal ones
that really are way more serious than a
physical headbutt yeah the other two
hacks that I think have saved our
marriage besides just showing up and
kind of using some of these things like
what's working what was hard is the
80/20 so everyone says marriage should
be 50/50
it's a biggest crock of [ __ ] I've
ever heard it's never 50/50 yeah ever
and so what we do is we quantify where
we are so if Steve comes home and he'll
be like I got 20 just in terms of energy
it's just energy investment kindness
patience
I'm not a guy 20 and I'll be like I'll
cover you
I got your brother like like I'll pull
the 80 sometimes we come home which we
have done a lot my mom has been sick and
I'll say I've got ten and Steve oh yes
you like two days ago said I'm riding a
solid 25 so we know that we have to sit
down at the table anytime we have less
than 100 combined and figure out a plan
of kindness toward each other I love
though yeah because the thing is
marriage is not something that's 50/50 a
partnership works when you can carry
there 20 are they can carry you're 20
and that when you both just have 20 you
have a plan where you don't hurt each
other yeah it's the your threadbare
right yeah and so so what we'll say is
I'm like I've got 10 and he'll be like I
got maybe 25 we're like put all the
groceries that are supposed to be great
and healthy in the freezer we're
ordering out get the housekeeper here an
extra day and we're canceling anything
with people that we really actually
don't like so how can we create some
buffer and we do that so like and then
you know then we'll like a day or two
later and like he'll be like I'm riding
a 60 I'm like oh my god work is kicking
my ass I'm still at a 20 he's like I got
you but we're a spare 20 so yeah was
that Charlie if he wants to skip water
polo practice today and let's all turn
in at 8 o'clock hmm like huge the other
thing I would say to that now I'm
thinking about that is we made a
determination very early there's kid
focused families
parent focused families and family focus
families we're a family focused family
so that means that if you want to do
water polo Eagle Scouts tennis and skeet
shooting and then that comes to the
family and the family agrees what will
keep the family healthy like we can we
you know I've got a book launch I've got
this Steve's got patients he's taking on
others you know he's a pediatrician and
he's doing this so what works for our
family right now is you can do two
extracurriculars and I'm going to have a
two-week tour not a four-week tour but
we put the family as the system that we
serve it's not the kids at the parents
cost or the parents of the kids cost
it's the family and it is it is
remarkable how do you weigh if you do it
all the the voting system so to speak
Rance if you all come to the table does
everyone have equal vote in the
decision-making process aspect like we
don't even [ __ ] around that it's
like when my kids like if I say like oh
[ __ ] my kids are like ooh you can't say
that I'm like I say anything I want you
can't say that and when you're old
enough you can do whatever you want when
you get your cursing line yeah yeah you
but right now I can totally do that
watch me but it's so we have very we
talk to our kids about everything we're
super open Steve and I both have veto
power and we rarely use it I bet I bet I
pulled out my veto card once in the last
five years
veto meaning kid says I want to do X and
you say Cathy or Steve or Steve yeah I'm
like I have to veto that I cannot do
that and then we really respect the veto
because we don't overuse it
so our our thing with our kids this is
my theory on parenting my my theory on
parenting is the best we can do is a
loving course from compliance to
commitment that your kids need to do
what you're asking them to do out of
compliance so don't run into the street
don't do this that's
that's you know you're not allowed to
watch that kind of TV you're not allowed
to play that kind of video game you need
to comply otherwise there's some natural
consequences at some point I've got a 14
year old now he's at other people's
house doing video right and so if all I
teach him is compliance and don't give
him the why about why you can't do that
if I don't say yes every time I can and
explain the knows then when he's there
and I can tell you that like we got a
call from a parent maybe a month ago and
said the boys were having a sleepover
they wanted to watch on though some
r-rated violent thing and Charlie said
can we watch something else you know my
parents are not cool with us hmm and he
could he didn't have to do that yeah but
he's moved to a commitment to our family
values because we say yes every time we
can we don't do any that stuff that my
parents did because I said no we
explained so in the voting process we'll
sit down and say here's the fall
semester or Charlie's like I've got
guitar I've got you know this I've got
this and I've got this I'd really love
to do this and this he's got here's what
my fault looks like you know we still
keep time in semesters here's what my
time looks like we're going to be able
to do two curriculars you can choose hmm
why not a lot of my friends are doing
those five totally understand different
families have different ways of
operating and it was like my daughter
when she went to high school she's a
junior now in college but we sat down
with her and said the number of AP
courses that you'll take will be limited
by your time you won't go to bed past
ten you will not miss a single dance you
will do something every weekend with
friends we will not participate in the
race to nowhere like you don't need to
graduate with 40 and she's a super
academic kid and she's like what you
know and like she's like but I need to
take this and then you take this I'm
like it's not gonna work that way and
then when she got to college we're like
we're not paying forward if you already
know what you want to be you're 18 so
what does that say more I'd like to hear
more on that so does that mean that you
wanted her to well actually not even
gonna speculate so could you elaborate
on that take every class that's
interesting to you
learn who you are because if I had a
dollar for every interview I did with a
late twenty or thirty year old that got
on the engineer lawyer a doctor path
because that was the moving escalator
for smart people who was depressed hated
what they did never even knew that you
could be a shoe designer or casting
director or a microphone builder if I
had a dollar for every one of those like
set for life set for life yeah and I
said you need to explore but you know
she's like this so cringy mom is so so
cringy like everyone the freshman
orientation knows exactly what they're
gonna be where they're gonna go to grad
school I'm like that's great that's not
the way we work yeah so you know I'll
call it like what are you taking she's
like taking a class on black power
movements Germany in the 20th century
statistics in multivariate analysis and
like wait I mean granted that spells
graduate school but you know she's like
as it turns out I don't think I want to
do this I don't want to do that and I'm
like super valuable and she's like no
are you sure it's as valuable as knowing
what you do want to do and like oh yeah
yeah knowing what you don't want to do
you get to save all the part in your 30s
and 40s where you hate work
you're drinking heavily you know like
you get to save a lot of that like
figure it out
nothing's wasted yeah yeah I graduate
from college when I was 29 hmm
it's like go see the world get a job
wait tables everyone I know is better at
who's waited tables a human being yeah
yeah I think everybody everyone should
have to work at least one porifera bleah
to service jobs yes yeah yeah you really
learn a lot yes yes I mean like that and
like that's what I always tell Ellen you
get one job where you're serving the
public and you have to ever do that ever
date a guy who's a dick to a waiter yeah
yeah so I'm going to suggest we could
talk for hours and hours and hours
because I know we have a finite amount
of time today that we do we switch to
the
the format that what was anticipated
yeah and did this previously with my
friend dr. Peter Tia and it was it was
fun so I want to try it again and it is
talking about things you're excited
about yeah we're thinking about things
you've changed your mind on and then
silly absurd stupid anything that you
love okay doing and I got my homework
I'm so glad we're gonna do this because
I did I prepped I know you know I like
my gold star person I got my gold stars
in my wallet and so why don't we start
and we'll go one from each okay Oh
bucket really is that okay or we could
do the other way how would you like to
do it oh no I want to do it batched you
want to batch it yeah okay let's batch
it is that me like being like I starting
my self into your process I'm all for it
okay would you like to start oh okay
okay Tim let's take five things I've
changed my mind about okay in the last
few years wonderful let's do it okay and
this is like a rapid fire you can you
can take as much or as little time on it
as you'd like I will probably ask some
follow-up questions but if I ruin five
things have changed my mind about in the
last few years further faster okay it
wasn't always my motto how can we go
further faster how we can go further
faster and then investors started coming
about five years ago and saying can we
invest in your business I'm like you
know we were thought leader like what
does that look like I'm like no I don't
want to do that so we kind of
self-funded learning platforms and ways
to scale the business further faster
I've learned through painstaking wierdly
have you ever heard this painstaking
success hmm I haven't I'm the only
person that like shut down businesses
that we're doing really well mmm because
I hated it yeah
so what I've done thing I've changed my
mind about is I'm a slower closer kind
of a person hmm I'm not a further faster
person so we've changed our Jim Collins
Hedgehog to scaling our own work to
creating world-class research and
content and partnering with people who
scale as opposed to scaling like I just
like we were hiring all these people and
getting new desks
I was like what's happening yeah it's
like scale the magic word yeah I'm not a
further faster person the further faster
I go the crazier I get and the slower
closer I am to my real life and grocery
shopping and unloading the dishwasher
and loving on people the better I am so
I'm a slower closer person
dang it number two sobriety is a
superpower hmm yes I thought it was like
a I never thought I was a pain in the
ass to be honest with you I have never
miss drinking no I'm miss drinking five
or six times in the 23 years I've been
sober mhm and I can't explain it to you
except it's when when my anxiety which I
can struggle with is so high that I feel
like the only thing that will put it out
is something that I shouldn't be using
mm-hmm so and I've never wanted a drink
when I'm in my food zone when you're in
your food zone yeah so my food zone is
pretty like my normal and I text you
about this all the time so what's your
advice but my food zone is my food zone
not because it's a thing but because
it's my food zone it's kind of Quito II
you know yeah so like I'm probably
insulin resistant from a lot of yo-yo
dieting my whole life and so just that
kind of macro of kind of high fat
moderate protein low carb is my jam and
I just feel good so you know I think of
my keto prick and it's binary which I
learned from you it's like when I texted
you like should I go slow carb or what
are you're thinking about this and
you're like the thing about keto that
you need to be careful about is the
binary nature of it you're on it or
often you're either in ketosis or you're
not right and so for me that helps me
with my with kind of the food addiction
stuff mm-hmm cuz I'm not a I'm not an
abstainer I'm not a moderator yeah yeah
I mean I totally understand yessum I'm
very binary yeah and so for me it's
great I just don't eat that stuff it's
not like I negotiate the bread basket I
just don't eat the bread basket and in
the big book they talk about when you
work a program you describe for people
with a big book is because I had never
even heard this term till yesterday
really yeah Alcoholics Anonymous big
book and I'm not a big I work to a for
the first year and in the last 22 years
I work my own program it's like God
components of a but it's also got some
Buddhist stuff in it and some kind of
daily examine Catholic stuff and my own
thing I won my own program with some
like serious accountability partners
like but in the a big book they write
one of the promises of sobriety
if you stay in fit spiritual condition
and do your work is the prop is the gift
of neutrality where you're neither
running as fast as you can away from the
booze or the food nor are you running a
weight you know you're not running for
it or away from it it's much neutral and
so for me like the bread basket now is
neutral the wine but my sobriety is
really a superpower I would attribute
including my marriage and the fact that
I'm proud of how to raise my kids and my
career to the fact that I'm sober
mmm-hmm that when [ __ ] gets hard I stay
in it mm-hmm yeah I mean as opposed to
trying to nominate dollar num yeah work
it out work it out work out it out drink
it out eat it out so I'd really changed
my mind of looking at from an albatross
to it's kind of a superpower no yeah
look though bangs I just got bangs I
like it
you got a really big curtain bang yeah
just bangs you're gonna get I'm getting
it implants just bang just forehead
curtains I changed my mind about bangs
usually I only got bangs in my 20s after
I broke up some [ __ ] so I would be
like cigarettes wine coolers and bangs
he always the answers to that
could be uh could be an ex memoir would
you like oh my god cigarettes bangs in a
wine cooler I'm in some [ __ ] just
broke up with her like yeah buy ten
copies yes
if you was in my last one I've got six
but I'm gonna just share four or five
okay
I've one thing I've changed my mind
about this is what our goes back to our
earlier conversation if you can't do it
how two percent don't bother mm-hmm yeah
I was like I'm not going to like cook
every meal at night until I can do this
class I really wanted with the CIA the
Culinary Institute of America you know
and now I'm like you know what my kind
of pretty good fish tacos is still a
family meal where we're sitting down
saying grace together and yeah like it's
good enough yeah yeah okay I see so used
to be the mantra used to be a hundred
percent or not at all yeah
I'm not gonna work out until my schedule
opens up for me to work out every day at
five o'clock right my schedule will
never do that I don't ever do that yeah
so like I'm doing like my little bands
and my stuff on my phone at my house or
whatever like like yeah the how do
perfectionism is not only a defense
mechanism it's the worst across the
nation to land there was a great
avoidance avoidance just real quickly I
will say sleep I've changed my mind
about sleep like why exercise eat well
any of that stuff if you're not sleeping
yeah sleep is like the best isn't it
yeah but no one and no one in your 30s
or 20s will believe you in functional
medicine I've changed my mind about that
okay five of serd stupid things let's do
it you do that last I'd say no let's
let's do the let's do the absurd stupid
stuff and then we'll go to exciting okay
so this was so interesting for me
because I as a qualitative researcher
really found a thematic analysis here
I've got some kind of unprocessed
problem with the British the British
yeah okay but okay so five of sort of
stupid fun things I do
Iwan movie night I get myself a movie
night because I love maybe me too I only
watch movie trailers huh yeah well I
watched like 20 movie trailer dopes do
you do that with judgy over there how
you do it on YouTube or how do you find
the travel trailers oh wow yeah yeah and
it's like the happiest place and like
ever it's not it's my it's like I
probably imminent light okay so I watch
movie trailers a movie night it's so
it's you get the whole emotional rush
yeah
a narrative 90-minute yeah I this is a
stupid thing I do I really am a bad
trash talker
and super competitive so whether it's
like ping pong or we play a lot of
family for square I play a lot of cards
I'm like a [ __ ] Tom yeah a terrible [ __ ]
talker you know I can see it I can see
oh my god yes you can see it I can see
okay so I'm obsessed with Rick Beato
videos on YouTube where who's Rick Beato
I don't know who that is he's a music
producer and so he does like the best
countdowns he does he's great countdown
so the 20 best acoustical intros to rock
songs and he's my age and so like yeah
the 20 best vocal like I really took a
problem with it like it took like he's a
Beatles fan so there's a lot of [ __ ] ton
of Beatles in there but so like let's
just do this three best vocal I'm a big
music person and a big rock'n'roll
person and Texas music present about to
get very much you gotta get stroked
I'm the magnet schools here okay so I
thought there would be only one song
that could be the number one vocal
introduction to a song what would your
guess would be you're thinking about
harmony harmony I'm already out of my
depth here Kansas Kansas okay yeah yeah
I was thinking Whitney Houston from the
bodyguard soundtrack but we're gonna I
love you Whitney
I love you Whitney too but this is
Austin Texas I know and I'm gonna take
you out one night and we're gonna watch
number could be out of it I'm ready okay
yeah so it was he did queen vehement
Rhapsody which I think good Kansas was
three paperback writer from the Beatles
was too I just take exception so I watch
all those a best acoustical guitar intro
all that's all like the 70s you know
like Jim Croce and staff bass electric
guitar I still have some issues with
some of his but I walked a lot of rock
piata Brickley out of videos okay oh wow
people goes down I'm me right change
your life yeah I'm ready
okay I watch a lot of British crime
procedurals hmm okay like oh yeah
crime procedural look you know like a
you know like Law & Order but you're -
uh-huh yes I watch like a ton a ton yes
goggle box goggle have you watched this
no I never heard of it okay it's I think
it's all over like a different countries
now but I watch the UK goggle ball box
it's where you watch people watching
television oh it's like response videos
so you get to see how they respond and
they and you you fall in love with these
families some it's obsessed with British
time crime procedurals and goggle box
goggle box yes also sounds like a near
future dystopian technological like
Terminator kind of thriller yes but it's
battle box there's no action at all it's
just like these like kind of normal
normal ordinary British families going
boy I mean and you're like I just
thought really hard and then tick tock
I've spent a lot of time watching tick
tock
really oh yeah I do get sent I tick tock
for me I it's kind of like I feel like
someone's peeking around a corner huh
late at night going yeah heroin $10 okay
I'm just like I can't I I'm afraid to go
on tech talk because I I can understand
why I would get hooked you have to on my
Instagram I just put my favorite
tick-tock all right all right let me do
it with you okay let me ask this
question would you rather eat okay a
baby goat mm-hmm or a matter baby or a
matter baby what's the matter baby
nothing's the matter what's wrong with
you oh my god is that from tektite my
kids say that I'm you got me that was
easy
please promise me like pinky swear right
now with your pinky that you will put a
link to this specific matter baby from
tick tock minor my on my episode
confirmed matter baby this is like this
Irish guy and his dad oh it's like not
to baby baby for [ __ ] sake not a baby
they say that more than I do Oh
they're good that I'm good undervalued
for is okay that was excellent
thanks so excited about okay
excited about two big things 2020 one is
that I am taking a visiting
professorship at Texas McCombs at UT
five so I'm gonna do be there for a year
and I'm bringing dear to lead to UT
Texas McCombs and so we're gonna do our
trainings out of the University of Texas
more research develop some cloud-based
tools for organizations to use it's
really exciting yeah go TX great yeah
cutie
I know amazing podcast the new podcast
the story I'm really excited
mmm-hmm what is the name of your podcast
unlocking us great very much thank you
very much what we were talking about
right um super excited about less travel
because I feel like the podcast may be a
way for me to do that that will eat you
up travel yeah yeah I'm so excited to be
parking here in Austin for a few months
straight I'm thrilled about it it's an I
look back it say my 20s when all I
wanted to do was travel meet you and
after a while you're like oh I feel like
George Clooney in that movie up in the
air yes I'm beginning yes to feel like
I'm never quite unpacking and I don't
like this feeling yeah and there's a lot
to be said for seeing new places and so
on but man do I love the sort of
energetic conservation of just having a
nice routine but don't you think routine
will set you free I do absolutely I date
you like yeah so I'm excited about a new
work thing that we're doing where 30% is
leading my team and my organization 70%
is white space creative time mmm well
I'll see if we can make it happen but
Bert that's great it's a big that's a
big percentage yeah what are you hoping
to do with that seventy percent or do
you have any idea what types of research
big research and so it's hard research
on human experience and so I I love that
like my happy place is like alone with
my data like that's
I rolled up watching curled up with your
data I do one more talk to you oh I'm
ready I'm ready for it okay I am going
to work on a new book I'm gonna write
more I'm going to think about maybe the
podcast is gonna take a lot of creative
white space for me because I want to be
really thoughtful yeah I feel like
you're really thoughtful like you think
through what you want to talk to people
about and I wanted like we have our
discernment lens for the podcast for
success for us is contribution mmm and
so if at any point I feel like a book
will not make a contribution I pull it
back yeah if at any point I feel like
this is just contributing to all the
[ __ ] in the noise I'm gonna pull it
back so I think in order to meet that
discernment goal of contribution I have
to be really thoughtful and I say think
that's gonna take creative space yeah
yeah I think you'll do great I also
think you have a you have an attunement
to other people's emotional states that
elicits
a lot of very vulnerable truth and I
think if you have that you're set
as far as contribution I think that
checks the box there's some of that
certainly there are a million plus
podcasts there there's some of that out
there but to get it consistently I think
is still quite difficult it's not as an
audio listener if you're looking for
those raw moments of truth and messiness
within which you can find and learn so
much I think you are very gifted at
doing that so if you if you do that
consistently I think you're in good
shape thanks I'll come to you from
entering I will make no claims to have
good answers but I can I can certainly
make up some answers and do my best okay
one last project huh let's do it okay I
have to put this down you can hold that
okay all this oh wow it's a graphic
tick-tock okay
what is this what does that looks like
to me looks like a butterfly okay
what are these wings okay and what is
one called a wing okay put your
microphone down and then give me two
thumbs up you have to get closer to me
okay now I want you to say the word that
you just said to me ten times fast hello
Wow all right
tick-tock first one's on us wing please
tell me there's an ED and like an Elmer
Fudd somewhere in that tick tock remix
we might be to like but this is my hash
tag wholesome tic toc I like it I love
it
well I'm so happy that you're gonna be
spending more time here in Austin yes
how exciting yeah
and where can people learn all about
your latest interests including tick
tock your latest projects where can
people best find you
Brene brown comm is all of the things
all the things yeah so nice to see you
again
you too so fun yeah so to be continued
yeah oh yes to be continued and for
everybody who's watching or listening
you can find show notes links to
everything we've talked about including
the promised tic toc videos in the show
notes at tim de blog for slash podcast
you